it was very interesting game um
but he he maybe got a little bit
impatient i feel that um just at one
point when he started pushing his pawns
uh and his time management has been
under five seconds he's gotta move
okay and now
queen takes rook or this rook move both
are winning blacks rook can no longer
guard the eighth rank white is about to
make a new queen what's about to win a
rook and duda knows it he knows that
this is the point where prague is just
going to lose
yep and okay one last check from prague
but the offer of a queen trade will end
the game if queens come off white is
simply winning and
heartbreak for prague yeah look at that
he is about to lose game one here
pragmata and there it is he resigns it's
over young christophe duda wins game one
all right remember pragnanda in the lead
in the tournament magnus carlsen he won
his first game and if magnus wins
today's match and prague loses they will
be
on the same score heading into the final
day pragnanda will